this is the charm laughs the
collaborative haptics and robotics in
medicine lab where we study interaction
with virtual world and robots through
the sense of touch primarily for medical
applications I'm Allison Okumura I'm a
professor in the department of
mechanical engineering at Stanford
University the word haptics means
anything having to do with the sense of
touch and it ranges from feeling
temperatures and textures to feeling
forces and motions of your limbs say
you're pouring a cup of coffee all of
the different components of your haptic
system come into play when you're doing
a task like this for starters the skin
where it contacts the cup feels local
stretch and vibration information that
might tell you if it's starting to slip
from your grasp and also as you put more
coffee in the cup it has increased
weight and you can feel those forces and
the muscles and tendons in your arm and
all of this information gets processed
together in the brain to both help you
recognize what is the task that you're
doing as well as control your movements
appropriately it's things that happen at
the interface between different fields
where much of the most exciting work
happens I think and suddenly my students
can come from a wide range of
backgrounds both an engineering and
computer science but also interacting
with people in education medicine and
science and Kerstin Kaplan is interested
in how humans and robots can work
together to perform surgical tasks there
are a lot of complex interactions that
we as humans have with the world that
really require the sense of touch to do
it right one example is to palpate and
soft tissue to find say a cancerous lump
this is the master console of The
DaVinci surgical robot when you place
your head in here there's two images
that you have one for each eye that
shows you a video of feet of what's
happening on the patient's side as you
move on that side it's going to cause
corresponding movements over here what
you end up doing is you put your hand
kind of in the grippers here so for
example if you have a pair of graspers
this would allow you to grasps and lift
something and you're able to move around
both sort of an X Y Z as well as
rotationally with this so as I move over
here
the robots gonna move following my
motions and so going up and down is
gonna cause the robot to palpate the
tissue and as soon as I hit the tissue I
can feel a force against me that
corresponds to the strength of the force
that that the robot tip is feeling and
we're getting that reaction thanks to
the force sensor on the tip and I can
tell when I push on this that I'm
getting more force back against my hand
whereas if I come over here and push
down I move a lot further before I
really get much sense of a force by
feeling that vent I can say oh there's
definitely something here I'm going to
explore this area further when you have
haptic feedback included that's a faster
reaction that I can feel it faster than
I can process looking at it one of our
goals is to understand how we can use
haptics in education we have an online
class associated with it to be a fully
participating stood in this course you
will need to build you're unhappy we
think there's a huge potential for using
a sense of touch to replace things that
are currently used to teach with vision
or with sound there are a lot of people
who really learn well from from hands-on
interaction so we've built these series
of haptic devices which we call HAP kits
for haptic kits where they can be
constructed from individual components
by a student and now that more and more
people have access to 3d printers we've
been designing these 3d printed versions
making it inexpensive and accessible to
lots of different people for example
we're doing an experiment with physics
and spring and you have a virtual
stiffness
that is a spring that's harder or softer
the student actually programs in the
quizon themselves and feels it and if
they program in the wrong equation it
doesn't feel like a spring anymore it
feels just like stopping just like a
stopping point we think that's a really
great way of giving students intuition
for complex topics like physics we sort
of think of it as a gateway haptic
device in that they could go and do more
complicated interesting creative things
than we can even think of just by having
these resources of low-cost inexpensive
prototyping techniques for haptics and
who knows where people will take it when
we interact with computers it's such a
kind of sensory impoverished interaction
so haptics I think it's very much gonna
grow in importance as we continue to
interact with computers and more
sophisticated ways we're going to new be
able to get feedback not just reach out
and touch the computers but have them
touch us back the charm lab is always
looking for new ways to use haptics to
improve the human condition other ideas
for the future include haptic devices
that you can reach out and feel they
form a kind of digital play that change
both their shape and also their
mechanical properties making somewhat
magical tangible objects that could be
one tool one minute and a different tool
the next minute the idea is that some of
these haptic technologies that we might
develop for one specific project and
really become morphed into very
different ideas as we keep pushing the
technology and start discovering what we
can do
I study a group of scorpions that belong
to the genus centroid East commonly
known as the bark scorpions and they
make venom that is intensely painful
hopefully the weather will hold good
rain might be beautiful might not rain
we got over 100 less it's always a it's
a gamble but